what's your favorite hakar Nakamura
video I don't know if I have any
specific favorite but anytime he start
losing and he's tilting that's that's
the most enjoyable for me what month was
aakara Nakamura born in December what
country was hiar Nakamura born in I
think hiar was born in Japan what city
of Japan um oaka what's his brother's
name Asuka Hikaru was the highest rated
player on the internet club with two
usernames do you know what those two
usernames were it has to be Smallville
and capano Bridge nailed it Hikaru has
authored one chess book do you know the
title I have the book that he's authored
it's about bullet chess I think it's
called like one minute Checkmate or
something yeah wow which TV show has
hkar Nakamura made a cameo appearance on
billions that's right they got him cuz
they couldn't get me which is a True
Story by the way